desde el principio de la existencia del
ser humano hemos estado contando cosas y
hemos buscado formas de recordar y
representar las cosas que contamos por
ejemplo si fueras un humano de la era
primitiva y quisiera saber cuántos días
pasan sin llover podrías decir ok no
llovió el día de hoy entonces llevamos
un día sin llover pero bueno o sea
ahorita utilizamos la palabra 1 pero tal
vez esa palabra ni siquiera existía en
ese entonces y después pasa otro día sin
llover y pasa otro día sin beber y otro
día y estamos en una sequía entonces
siguen pasando los días y pasa otro día
sin llover y de repente llueve y
entonces llega a una amiga tuya y te
pregunta oye tú no sabes más o menos
hace cuántos días que no llueve y
entonces tú puedes decir si los he
estado contando
hace cuántos días que no llueve tu amigo
lo ve fijamente y dice ok
tengo una noción general de hace cuánto
que no llueve y en algún punto se dan
cuenta de que sería muy útil ponerles
nombres a estas cosas así es que
decidimos a este llamarle uno a este
llamarle dos a esto llamarle tres cuatro
cinco seis y siete obviamente cada
idioma en el mundo tiene distintos
nombres para cada uno de estos y hay un
montón de lenguas perdidas que tenían
otros nombres para ellos pero muy
rápidamente te empiezas a dar cuenta que
esta es una forma muy estorbosa e
ineficiente de representar cantidades o
números para empezar te tardas mucho
tiempo en escribirlo utiliza mucho
espacio si alguien quiere leer este
número y saber cuántos días han pasado
sin llover o cuántas ovejas tiene el
vecino tiene que sentarse a contar otra
vez
cada uno de estos palitos
y ya es suficientemente tardado con 7
imagínate ahora si fueran 27 o 1000
entonces seguramente llenaríamos una
página completa y tu amigo se sentaría a
tomar el té a la hora de contar estos
pelitos y podemos estar seguros de que
cometería algún error en el camino para
resolver este problema a los humanos en
algún punto se les ocurrió inventar los
sistemas numéricos ahora esos sistemas
numéricos son cosas que todos nosotros
tomamos por sentado a veces sentimos que
es la forma en la que siempre hemos
contado creemos que es la única forma
natural pero espero que durante este
vídeo empieces a apreciar la belleza que
hay dentro de los sistemas numéricos y
que nuestro sistema numérico no es el
único sistema numérico que hay el
sistema numérico al que casi todos
estamos acostumbrados es el sistema en
base 10
base 10 también llamado sistema numérico
decimal y porque 10 bueno probablemente
porque tenemos 10 dedos que nos ayudan a
contar y por lo tanto es muy natural
pensar en contar las cosas en grupos de
10 y tener 10 símbolos y después puedes
contar cuántos grupos de 10 hay ya sea
con tus dedos o con los símbolos y así
saber cuántas cosas hay más rápido y más
fácil como necesitábamos 10 símbolos se
nos ocurrió inventar al 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 y 9 estos 10 dígitos son los 10
símbolos que usamos en el sistema base
10 y para hacer un pequeño recordatorio
de cómo los usamos piensa en el número
231 231
qué representa esto lo padre de los
sistemas numéricos es que tenemos
distintos valores por lugar este lugar
hasta la derecha es el lugar de los unos
nos esto literalmente significa un 1 es
una rayita un grupo de una rayita
este es el lugar de las decenas
d
cenas
este símbolo este 3 en este lugar
significa tres decenas tres grupos de
diez y diez palitos o diez cosas
previstas que son tres grupos de diez de
esas cosas y este dos de aquí está en el
lugar de las centenas
de los grupos de 100 objetos 100 palitos
o 100 cosas o 100 unos y entonces
representa dos grupos de 100
ahora me parece que ahorita podrías
pensar que hay algo raro por aquí y si
definitivamente hay algo raro aquí o sea
tenemos aquí decenas centenas así es que
en este lugar lo que debimos haber
escrito es unidades unidades porque esta
es la forma que utilizan nuestros
maestros para este lugar ok
así como hablamos de decenas cuando nos
referimos a grupos de diez objetos y
centenas cuando nos referimos a grupos
de cien objetos cuando nos referimos a
grupos de un solo objeto hablamos de
unidades el único problema es que más
adelante vamos a tener que hablar de
grupos de dos objetos o de grupos de
nueve objetos y no tenemos palabras tan
bonitas como éstas para referirnos a
esos grupos entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es que cuando tengamos que hablar
de un grupo de dos objetos
dos objetos objetos vamos a referirnos a
estos grupos de dos objetos como 2 es 2
es así es que si estamos hablando de
cinco grupos de dos objetos vamos a
decir que tenemos 5 2 es y también lo
podemos abreviar con 12 seguido de una s
así es que aquí podríamos estar hablando
de 3 10 s 10
y de 200
en dos y claro también estaríamos
hablando de un
1 pero bueno esta anotación es sólo una
forma más general de hablar de los
grupos de varios objetos porque para
otros números no tenemos palabras tan
bonitas como centenas o decenas o
unidades pero bueno en este mismo vídeo
vamos a usar esta anotación pero déjame
borró todo esto
muy bien
y de una vez vamos a llamarle a esto
unos bueno pero nos quedamos a la mitad
de algo muy interesante el chiste es que
tenemos dos grupos de 100 tres grupos de
diez y un grupo de uno y ahora
los sumamos
y una vez más yo sigo pensando en el
sistema base 10 los sumamos y obtenemos
231 ok esto es 2% por grupos de 100 son
200 más tres grupos de 10 o sea 30 más
un grupo de 1 que es un 1 y entonces nos
queda 231 y observa esto
en nuestro sistema base 10 cada vez que
nos movemos un lugar a la izquierda
estamos pensando en grupos de 10 lo que
teníamos en este lugar aunque hay grupos
de 10 entonces este es el lugar de los
12 lo multiplicamos por 10 y llegamos al
lugar de los 10 es o sea al lugar de las
decenas al lugar de los grupos de 10 y
si quieres ir al siguiente lugar
multiplicas por 10 otra vez y obtienes
el lugar de las centenas o sea el lugar
de los grupos de 100 objetos
si estás familiarizado con los
exponentes podemos pensar a los unos
como la potencia de 10 elevada a la 0
que es simplemente un 1 y entonces si
nos vemos un lugar hacia la izquierda
multiplicamos por 10 y tenemos 10 a la 1
que es simplemente un 10 y nos damos
otro lugar a la izquierda así es que
multiplicamos otra vez por 10 y tenemos
es a las dos que es simplemente siente y
obviamente puedes seguir yendo a la
izquierda todo lo que quieras ese es el
poder de nuestro sistema numérico base
10 entonces puede ser que ahora tengas
más curiosidad qué pasa hacia aquí
tenemos otro número en lugar del 10
hagámoslo
lo más sencillo posible bueno incluso
podemos ver esto como un sistema base 1
únicamente tenemos un símbolo aquí pero
qué tal que nos vamos a algo ligeramente
más complejo
un sistema base 2
base 2 y resulta que no sólo podemos
hacer esto sino que el sistema base 2
también llamado sistema binario es la
base de todos los sistemas de
computación todas las cuentas
operaciones y la matemática que hay de
fondo cuando las computadoras hacen
cualquier cosa están escritas y se
desarrollan en el sistema binario y en
él tenemos dos símbolos el 0 y el 1 y la
razón por la que esto es útil para la
computación es porque todo el hardware
que utilizamos para construir las
computadoras todos los transistores y
las puertas lógicas se encuentran en un
estado prendido o apagado ok prendido o
apagado
por ejemplo cuando usas tu calculadora
tú estás operando en el sistema decimal
y la calculadora te enseña los números
del sistema decimal pero en el fondo
está haciendo las operaciones en el
sistema binario ahora cómo lo podemos
hacer para pensar en este sistema
binario pues podemos construir lugares
de valor parecidos a estos de aquí pero
en lugar de tomar las potencias de 10
ahora vamos a tomar las potencias de 2
así es que pongamos algunos lugares por
acá hasta la derecha vamos a poner 2 a
las 0 que bueno 2 a la 0 es un 1 así es
que a este lugar hasta la derecha lo
podemos seguir llamando el lugar de los
unos luego tenemos dos a la 1 y eso es
un 2 así es que este es el lugar de los
dos luego tenemos 2 a las 22 a las dos
es cuatro así es que este es el lugar de
los 42 a la 3
8 y mira cada vez que pasamos de un
lugar a otro estamos multiplicando por
dos aquí también estamos multiplicando
por 2 y aquí también estamos
multiplicando por dos al igual que
cuando estábamos aquí que teníamos que
multiplicar por 10 para pasar de un
lugar al siguiente
así es que pues sigamos y ahora
multiplicamos por dos y tenemos 2 a la 4
es 16 2 a las 5 32
2 a las 6 64 2 a las 7 este es el lugar
de los 128 y podemos seguir hacia la
izquierda todo lo que queramos pero creo
que esto es suficiente para representar
a 231 en el sistema binario y en los
próximos videos te voy a enseñar cómo
hacerlo pero en este vídeo vamos a
empezar simplemente por representarlo en
el sistema binario 231 se puede
representar como tenemos que poner un 1
en el lugar de 228 luego en el lugar de
los 64 también vamos a poner un 1 y en
el lugar de los 32 es también vamos a
poner un 1 sin embargo en el lugar de
los 16 es vamos a poner ahora un 0 y en
el lugar de los hechos también vamos a
poner un 0 pero en el lugar de los 4 ya
vamos a poner un 1 otra vez
en el lugar de los dos es otro uno y en
el lugar de los unos va a ir otro uno
también y todo esto lo que significa es
simplemente que aquí tenemos uno de
estos cientos veintiocho más uno de
estos sesenta y cuatro más uno de estos
32 es más cero de estos 16 608 más 14
más 12 más 11 ok
tal cual tal cual como aquí teníamos un
1 más 310 es más 200 y bueno podemos ver
que estos dos son lo mismo
ok aquí tenemos uno de 128 128 + 1 64 64
más un 32 un 32 más y bueno aquí tenemos
0 16 608 y finalmente más 14 14 más
12 12 más 11 suma todos estos y vas a
ver que te queda 231 ahora otra vez a la
hora de hacer la suma de hecho nada más
al escribir todos estos números estamos
utilizando el sistema numérico al que
estamos más acostumbrados que es
obviamente el sistema decimal pero el
chiste es que esto de aquí representa en
el sistema binario esta suma de valores
que en el sistema decimal representamos
como 231 ok estas dos son simplemente
dos representaciones distintas de la
misma cantidad y ninguna es mejor que la
otra ojala que encuentres todo esto muy
interesante a mi esto la verdad es que
me abrió la mente y me hizo ver el poder
de nuestro sistema decimal en los
próximos vídeos vamos a ver otros
sistemas numéricos
obviamente el sistema decimal es el más
utilizado entre los humanos el sistema
binario es el más utilizado en las
computadoras pero otro sistema numérico
que también se utiliza muchísimo es el
sistema numérico hexadecimal donde no
tienes ni dos dígitos ni diez dígitos
sino 16 dígitos y vamos a explorar a
fondo esos sistemas numéricos y cómo se
puede pasar de un sistema a otro